Caption: alrighty
Caption: welcome back everyone to our I think a
Caption: final session in Jackal Negal today uh
Caption: with us is Ryan folds he's discussing
Caption: the war on Tech Talent Ryan is a
Caption: technical Talent acquisition specialist
Caption: who has been recruiting in the Perth
Caption: technology market for the last five
Caption: years he recruits cross data analytics
Caption: Cloud cyber security and I.T projects
Caption: pretty much covers it all I think for
Caption: two well-recognized recruitment agencies
Caption: he's currently the talent acquisition
Caption: specialist Serbian a cloud and data
Caption: focused company led by a highly talented
Caption: team of technical consultants and he's
Caption: also one of the current wa chapter leads
Caption: for the Australian women and security
Caption: network promoting connection support and
Caption: inspiration for women in the cyber
Caption: security industry
Caption: please welcome Ryan
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you very much Dave and thank you
Caption: everyone for coming here to watch this
Caption: today this is my first day conference
Caption: first time I've been to one and first
Caption: one that I'm presenting at so please be
Caption: gentle
Caption: um hands up if you've tried to hire a
Caption: software engineer in the last 12 or so
Caption: months
Caption: cool uh what about a data engineer in
Caption: the last 12 months
Caption: cool and Cloud engineers
Caption: they're hot yeah
Caption: so this presentation should be pretty
Caption: relevant for everybody in the room then
Caption: my name is Ryan folds um you might know
Caption: me from such places as your LinkedIn
Caption: message box
Caption: um
Caption: I've been recruiting in the Perth
Caption: technology market for the last five or
Caption: so years across two large agencies
Caption: applications development data
Caption: engineering data science devops cyber
Caption: and pretty much everything else in
Caption: between
Caption: I started working as a talent
Caption: acquisition Town acquisition specialist
Caption: with a business called Serbian so
Caption: Serbian is a technology Consulting
Caption: business we're a collection of
Caption: passionate problem solvers of Technology
Caption: agnostic individuals that like really
Caption: just working on cool stuff and sharing
Caption: and sort of collaborating on some of the
Caption: knowledge that we have
Caption: um so the the Serbian brand it's it's
Caption: been pretty well known and in the east
Caption: coast we've been around for about 15
Caption: years but the Perth branch has only
Caption: launched in August of 2021 so it's it's
Caption: reasonably new uh for Perth at least
Caption: so the Great War for technology is upon
Caption: us
Caption: and it's been upon us for some time now
Caption: but the game has definitely changed in
Caption: order to combat closed borders uh
Caption: restricted travel and just a generally
Caption: adverse attitude towards changing jobs
Caption: amid a pandemic as you'd expect the
Caption: Perth technology Market has really had
Caption: to undergo an evolution in terms of
Caption: talent
Caption: um and serbian's no different from any
Caption: other business in the room you know the
Caption: main challenge for a lot of businesses
Caption: pretty much all technology businesses in
Caption: Perth is how do we attract and retain
Caption: the best possible talent in the market
Caption: as a business we're still working on
Caption: this we're still fine-tuning this
Caption: process but there's a number of talent
Caption: acquisition strategies that we've put in
Caption: place over the last 12 or so months to
Caption: grow from a team of four to a team of 31
Caption: technical consultants working with some
Caption: of the latest in Cloud technology
Caption: I walked into the serving office in
Caption: August of 2021
Caption: um I probably didn't do my due diligence
Caption: at the time and didn't actually realize
Caption: how small the team was so I walked into
Caption: the building and one of the principal
Caption: Consultants said Yep this is it all four
Caption: of us
Caption: great
Caption: um so at that point I really I knew two
Caption: things one I wasn't going to be made
Caption: redundant anytime soon and two we've got
Caption: a lot of work ahead of us
Caption: I was essentially tasked with building
Caption: the per team from the ground up the
Caption: regional partner at the time had
Caption: basically said to me look if you can
Caption: find a couple of you know software
Caption: professionals or devops engineers in the
Caption: first 12 months great fantastic now I'd
Caption: heard along the Grapevine that our
Caption: Brisbane office had gone from zero to 65
Caption: technical consultants in about three
Caption: years I was not gonna let Brisbane beat
Caption: me apparently recruiters by Nature are
Caption: very competitive people
Caption: um so yeah look you know 12 months later
Caption: we've been able to successfully build a
Caption: team of 31 technical consultants across
Caption: data engineering devops engineering
Caption: Cloud engineering cyber security and
Caption: software development
Caption: so again why is this presentation every
Caption: relevant to everybody in the room well
Caption: all we have to do is just look at seek
Caption: and look at some of the adverts that are
Caption: currently advertised
Caption: now before we get stuck in let's just
Caption: take a second to have a look at the
Caption: Perth market in terms of the Perth
Caption: technology Market please keep in mind
Caption: that this was a study that I did
Caption: actually with thank you to the Robert
Caption: Walters team who helped me with some of
Caption: the insights but this is based on
Caption: statistics that are only available on
Caption: LinkedIn so if a person hasn't got their
Caption: profile on LinkedIn they're obviously
Caption: not included in the study
Caption: so according to LinkedIn we have
Caption: 3241 software Professionals in Perth
Caption: so that's not a whole heap much to my
Caption: disappointment and probably everyone's
Caption: disappointment software developers don't
Caption: grow on trees
Caption: um of the
Caption: 3241 software Professionals in Perth in
Caption: the last 12 months we've had 749 change
Caption: job which is about 23 of the Perth
Caption: Market
Caption: 16 of the Perth software professional
Caption: Market identifies female and the average
Caption: tenure with any organization is one and
Caption: a half years
Caption: this is just a quick breakdown on the
Caption: actual dynamics of the um the software
Caption: Dev market so we've got about 2 000
Caption: software developers about 700 or so
Caption: senior software engineers and a couple
Caption: of other positions in there as well
Caption: let's have a look at data engineers
Caption: so again these stats are only based on
Caption: what's actually out there on LinkedIn
Caption: um
Caption: so you can see here that we've got a
Caption: total of 263 data Engineers senior data
Caption: engineers and other related data
Caption: professional titles in the market
Caption: of the 263 94 have changed jobs in the
Caption: last 12 months which is pretty
Caption: staggering that's 35 36 percent of the
Caption: entire Market has moved job within data
Caption: Engineering in the last 12 months
Caption: um diversity probably fares slightly
Caption: better with 26 of the market identifying
Caption: as female and again the average median
Caption: tenature with any organization is one
Caption: and a half years
Caption: uh this is a scary one we've only got 52
Caption: senior data engineers in Perth I feel
Caption: like there's something wrong with that
Caption: but
Caption: um lastly we'll have a look at another
Caption: really challenging skill set to hire in
Caption: Perth which is cloud professionals
Caption: so again according to LinkedIn the cloud
Caption: technology Market tells us that there
Caption: are 253 Cloud technology professionals
Caption: listed on LinkedIn
Caption: of the 253 C 69 have changed job in the
Caption: past 12 months 12 of the market
Caption: identifies female and again the the
Caption: median tenure with an organization is
Caption: one and a half years
Caption: so what does this tell us about the tech
Caption: Market in Perth
Caption: it's pretty tight it's pretty tight I
Caption: think that we can all agree that you
Caption: know we're all hiring these skill sets
Caption: they're all very similar sorts of skill
Caption: sets we're all doing really interesting
Caption: projects
Caption: um so naturally we're all looking for
Caption: the same sorts of professionals to help
Caption: us on that Journey
Caption: so how do we overcome this challenge
Caption: maths and relationships
Caption: so back when I first started in
Caption: recruitment my boss at the time Jody
Caption: hi she told me that the math doesn't lie
Caption: when it comes to recruitment now when I
Caption: was 23 years old and was six months into
Caption: recruitment didn't really believe it too
Caption: much but looking back on it now that
Caption: I've matured a little bit more I very
Caption: much believe that effective recruitment
Caption: in today's market especially in Perth
Caption: consists of two really key elements and
Caption: that is maths and relationships
Caption: but Ryan how does maths relate to
Caption: recruitment don't you just call people
Caption: up and ask them about opportunities and
Caption: jobs
Caption: it's a great question
Caption: so I'd be interested to hear maybe some
Caption: stats from the people in the crowd
Caption: especially recruiters and and talent
Caption: acquisition specialists in the room
Caption: um maybe at a later date but look for
Caption: the time being I'm happy to use my
Caption: statistics with Serbian as a bit of an
Caption: example
Caption: so in the last 12 months Serbian Perth
Caption: has had 1 210 applications across a
Caption: number of different professions so
Caption: software development data engineering
Caption: devops cloud and cyber security
Caption: of those 1210 applications will take 243
Caption: through to the first round of interview
Caption: 90 will make it through to the technical
Caption: exercise that we have so we we get
Caption: everyone to undergo a technical exercise
Caption: and of the 220 that take the exercise
Caption: only 118 will pass
Caption: 118 will go through to the second round
Caption: of interview which is with one of our
Caption: principal Consultants
Caption: 61 making it through to the final round
Caption: of interview
Caption: so it brings us to a grand total of 39
Caption: being offered and 28 accepting
Caption: so what does the maths tell us so look
Caption: let's work it back let's let's look at
Caption: what does it take to hire 28 talented
Caption: technologists across a 12-month period
Caption: I'll need to speak to roughly
Caption: 25.521 candidates a week which is
Caption: roughly five candidates a day
Caption: I need to interview 5.06 qualified
Caption: candidates a week one a day
Caption: I need to have at least 2.46 candidates
Caption: at a second round interview
Caption: and 1.27 candidates at a final round
Caption: interview
Caption: so in order to hire two or three
Caption: candidates per month
Caption: um that's sort of what we need to do in
Caption: terms of process from an interview and
Caption: recruitment point of view
Caption: now if you're wondering you know we've
Caption: got a talent acquisition team we've got
Caption: a recruitment team maybe why are they
Caption: not looking at or why they're not
Caption: getting the same sorts of results
Caption: um from my internal team I'd probably
Caption: encourage you just to have a look at I
Caption: suppose working it backwards and
Caption: re-engineering that process
Caption: um you know looking at how efficient how
Caption: effective that process is and hopefully
Caption: the answers should lie in there for you
Caption: now in addition to this we've
Caption: highlighted just how
Caption: tight the Perth Market can be so we need
Caption: to really be thinking about how our
Caption: brand is engaging with those
Caption: 3241 software developers in Perth how am
Caption: I managing relationships with the 263
Caption: data Engineers or how am I being
Caption: perceived by the 253 Cloud Professionals
Caption: in Perth
Caption: so we know what the challenges are
Caption: finding talents really hard
Caption: through the pandemic there's been some
Caption: real constraints around the movement of
Caption: human capital
Caption: and now that things are sort of returned
Caption: to a level of normality
Caption: yeah I don't know about you but 263 data
Caption: engineers in Perth is that's just not
Caption: enough as according to LinkedIn so the
Caption: challenge for us is how do we open up
Caption: this talent pool how do we how do we
Caption: widen the market that we currently have
Caption: so
Caption: let's explore Interstate Talent
Caption: um Perth is a pretty cool place to live
Caption: reasonably I suppose
Caption: the standard of living is is pretty good
Caption: house prices aren't the same as what
Caption: they are in Sydney so seratoway I think
Caption: we've got some really good things going
Caption: for us as a state I reckon I would have
Caption: probably
Caption: one in ten candidates come through the
Caption: process that will come from Melbourne or
Caption: Sydney
Caption: um and they'll come to us with the
Caption: reasons of
Caption: Perth is a great place to live it's a
Caption: great place to raise a family I can
Caption: afford a house that's a really good
Caption: start in addition to that
Caption: um you know let's look at maybe some of
Caption: the um the skilled migrants that we
Caption: could potentially explore
Caption: so earlier this year the West Australian
Caption: government and the federal government
Caption: put in place some changes to the
Caption: legislation around easing of movement
Caption: for skilled migrants so the Perth Metro
Caption: region was essentially reclassified as a
Caption: regional area so this has really opened
Caption: the door for a number of different
Caption: migrants from all over the country who
Caption: are Keen to work in Australia but are
Caption: obviously limited with regards to
Caption: Opportunities
Caption: um
Caption: and it's an interesting thing to think
Caption: about prior to this you know yes you
Caption: could potentially come and work in in
Caption: Perth as a devops engineer but you'd
Caption: have to go and work in the bush
Caption: wouldn't really make a lot of sense
Caption: especially you know when you're trying
Caption: to build collaborative teams
Caption: so the changes made by the wa government
Caption: basically enabled priority processing of
Caption: regional visas and Perth has now been
Caption: reclassified as a regional Zone
Caption: um in addition to that access to
Caption: Regional occupations list which has
Caption: obviously been opened out so there's
Caption: more jobs that have actually been
Caption: included on that list of potential
Caption: employability so as a result of this I
Caption: found we've had a real influx of people
Caption: looking to actually Fast Track some of
Caption: their visas
Caption: um you know in Melbourne and Sydney
Caption: people can be waiting upwards of six to
Caption: nine months for a potential Visa but
Caption: with the West Australian government
Caption: sending out invitations to apply for the
Caption: 190 Visa they really are trying to drive
Caption: a lot of people you know getting across
Caption: the state or getting across the country
Caption: into wa
Caption: so whilst we're on the topic of
Caption: international candidates or people
Caption: relocating I had a really good
Caption: interesting conversation with one of our
Caption: senior devops Engineers who's just
Caption: joined us not so long ago
Caption: um I was asking sort of about his
Caption: experience and just a bit of context so
Caption: gcp AWS like five or six years of
Caption: experience just a brilliant guy
Caption: um you know a skill set that is really
Caption: highly in demand especially in the Perth
Caption: Market but really any market and I was
Caption: talking to him about his his
Caption: um how he felt about our process and you
Caption: know I put the question to him of were
Caption: you interviewing with anybody else any
Caption: other organizations in Australia when
Caption: you were looking to make the move and he
Caption: said to me that he'd applied for 51 51
Caption: positions and he'd heard back from two
Caption: which is us who snagged him and there
Caption: was one other organization in Melbourne
Caption: so this is a devops and Cloud
Caption: professional who's applied for devops
Caption: and Cloud related positions and he's
Caption: only heard back from two organizations
Caption: so I think like this is a really
Caption: old-school way of thinking
Caption: um you know we're shutting we're crying
Caption: out as an industry for technologists
Caption: with all these specialized skills but if
Caption: you're not in Perth then sorry you don't
Caption: get a look in
Caption: um in in Serbian and Perth we've
Caption: recruited five candidates from all over
Caption: the world including Argentina South
Caption: India Guernsey which is a little island
Caption: halfway between France and the UK
Caption: tiny little place
Caption: um
Caption: but yeah look it's it's it's not really
Caption: that hard you know you just you get
Caption: yourself partnered with a really good
Caption: migration agent who know what they're
Caption: doing I can recommend one after this if
Caption: you would like we undertake a few
Caption: processes you've got to obviously get
Caption: the right sort of documentation together
Caption: um you've got to do a market skills
Caption: Market skills assessment which again
Caption: doesn't take too long
Caption: um and you know you look at obviously
Caption: the um the costs as well and yes it is a
Caption: reasonably large
Caption: commitment by the business you're
Caption: forking out about thirteen or fourteen
Caption: thousand dollars for an individual on a
Caption: four-year Visa which is a 482
Caption: um skills nominated Visa but when we
Caption: look at this you know in the grand
Caption: scheme of things you break that 14 Grand
Caption: down it's what three four thousand
Caption: dollars a year across a four year period
Caption: straight away we also I suppose we we
Caption: fight back against two of the really key
Caption: challenges that we're facing as an
Caption: industry which is broadening out that
Caption: talent pool outside of just Perth and wa
Caption: and we also beat the um the median
Caption: tenure with an organization because the
Caption: market dictates people stay with an
Caption: organization for one and a half years
Caption: the Visa obviously we're investing in
Caption: them they're investing in us with us for
Caption: a period of about four years or so so
Caption: it's a really handy thing to look into
Caption: now this is an important one
Caption: Talent attracts Talent
Caption: so you know in order to sort of attract
Caption: good talent we need to understand what
Caption: motivates Talent now how do we do this
Caption: it's pretty easy
Caption: honest transparent conversations with
Caption: our distinguished technologists about
Caption: what they're doing what they want to do
Caption: and how we can put a roadmap and a
Caption: strategy together to get them where they
Caption: want to go
Caption: once we understand you know what our
Caption: people want to do in their experience
Caption: with the business we can put these
Caption: things in place and we really want to
Caption: empower them to be ambassadors for our
Caption: business
Caption: um another really important aspect of
Caption: this is being able to provide a
Caption: financial incentive
Caption: um this should always come in a monetary
Caption: form and the successful referral of
Caption: candidates to our business at all levels
Caption: of seniority attracts an 8 000 referral
Caption: bonus
Caption: um which I find is well and truly enough
Caption: to motivate people to have conversations
Caption: with old colleagues and and get people
Caption: to flick me the CV and have a just a
Caption: general conversation
Caption: so if we're recruiting for technologists
Caption: in Perth whether we like it or not we're
Caption: in the Great Wall for technology Talent
Caption: the Landscapes ever changing and in
Caption: order to retain and grow our teams of
Caption: distinguished technologists we've got to
Caption: change with the times
Caption: so embracing visas you know empowering
Caption: our staff and looking at maths and
Caption: relationships when it comes to
Caption: recruitment
Caption: um you know this is how we've become one
Caption: of the fastest growing technical
Caption: consultancies in Perth in the last 12
Caption: months we've got an industry that are
Caption: essentially crying out for technologists
Caption: at the moment and recruiters love
Caption: telling me Oh it's really hard to find
Caption: Talent at the moment
Caption: I fundamentally believe this statement's
Caption: wrong it's actually not that hard it's
Caption: challenging yes it's not easy at times
Caption: but if you actually take the time to
Caption: think outside of the box you know adopt
Caption: different ways of doing things and
Caption: change the way that you're approaching
Caption: the game I think you'd be quite
Caption: surprised by what you find
Caption: that's pretty much it for me I just
Caption: wanted to say thank you very much to all
Caption: the sponsors
Caption: um today wouldn't be possible without
Caption: them so thank you very much
Caption: and have a chat with me
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you very much Ryan
Caption: we do have a couple of minutes for any
Caption: questions for Ryan that the room might
Caption: have uh are there any questions
Caption: yes
Caption: the biggest green light I love it when
Caption: people tell me throw me at your hardest
Caption: challenge and I'll come up with a
Caption: solution
Caption: um that's a really big one like for us
Caption: it's it's
Caption: about problem solving you know it's it's
Caption: the ability to be able to break
Caption: something down and logically work
Caption: through it to come up with a solution so
Caption: that's a really big green light the
Caption: other one's sort of passion for what
Caption: they're doing so don't show me about
Caption: don't tell me about stuff that you're
Caption: doing in work tell me about the stuff
Caption: you're doing outside of work um because
Caption: that's obviously where passion shines
Caption: through and communication is the other
Caption: really key one
Caption: become some recruiters give other
Caption: recruiters
Caption: and yeah can we say like not all
Caption: recruiters but what do you think is
Caption: good
Caption: and what do you think
Caption: oh good question I've met both I like to
Caption: think I'm one over the other
Caption: um what makes a good tech recruiter is
Caption: someone that's not looking to close a
Caption: sale
Caption: I think that's a really big one
Caption: um so yeah someone that's not looking to
Caption: close a sale someone that's looking to
Caption: build relationships over the long term
Caption: um and put the candidate first that's
Caption: that's going to be the main like the
Caption: number one thing and I think that's the
Caption: trouble with recruitment because it's
Caption: Recruitment and sort of sales as well so
Caption: sometimes the sales aspect can be to
Caption: detriment of the candidate what makes a
Caption: bad recruiter someone that doesn't do
Caption: that someone that pings you know 100
Caption: messages out on LinkedIn just to try and
Caption: take a bit of a phishing approach
Caption: um
Caption: yeah
Caption: and they have a certain budget
Caption: what in your opinion how should they
Caption: what what's the best way for
Caption: eign
Caption: best return on investment for driving
Caption: recruitment
Caption: cool
Caption: um like we we take the approach of
Caption: you know the the best candidate is the
Caption: best candidate doesn't matter how they
Caption: come we want to try and enable as many
Caption: channels as possible to open that up
Caption: every business is going to be different
Caption: um I'm a big fan of investing in the TA
Caption: team internally
Caption: um you know you especially I think if
Caption: you Empower them to to be able to do a
Caption: really good job and engage with the
Caption: market
Caption: um you know a lot of the time at least
Caption: from what I found they can do the job of
Caption: three agencies combined because they
Caption: understand the business just that little
Caption: bit more
Caption: on a little bit more of a personal level
Caption: at least that's what I found you know
Caption: when I started at Serbian there was a
Caption: big shift in mindset from agency to
Caption: internal you know it's not about okay
Caption: I'm going to recruit this position for
Caption: this business and then next week it's on
Caption: to this business like the person I
Caption: recruit is going to be sitting next to
Caption: me
Caption: um so it's just it's a little bit more
Caption: of a slowed down approach so it's hard
Caption: to say linkedin's a big one linkedin's a
Caption: massive one at least for me I reckon at
Caption: least
Caption: half of the people that I've actually
Caption: gone out and sourced have been through
Caption: Linkedin probably more than half to be
Caption: honest
Caption: okay we do it one one more but then we
Caption: have to break a copy so
Caption: um so that's a lot of the numbers you're
Caption: talking about working and I'm just
Caption: curious as a software Engineers have
Caption: never been on LinkedIn
Caption: I'm not too sure to be honest I wouldn't
Caption: know I'd love to like that's probably
Caption: the evolution of this is maybe doing a
Caption: bit more of a study to unearth how many
Caption: actually aren't on LinkedIn
Caption: um you know it's it's
Caption: something I see a lot in cyber security
Caption: as well as there'll be no trace of of
Caption: some of the best cyber Security
Caption: Professionals in the Perth market and
Caption: for good reason
Caption: um so no idea
Caption: all right well as I said we do a coffee
Caption: and
Caption: um
Caption: [Applause]